the business day is coming to an end at
Davos and it's been remarkable a few
highlights thank you there's another
campaign against female genital usage
for men that's yeah i'll follow up last
year my heart is going i was fantastic
he's promised to follow up he said it's
a fantastic cause and if i can get into
clinton initiative that will be
wonderful and i think he will come so
that's great
I had ten minutes with Klaus Schwab who
is the founder product money born again
he was very much behind me bringing this
cause here trust i think in order to you
to solve those issues you need really to
engage all stakeholders and it's costly
NGO community its business its politics
its young global leaders so that's one
necessity to really make focus I met
Paulo Coelho here is a personal grief
from big and just to see him in the
flesh have him shake my hand so warmly
it's amazing they vote for you where so
I'm so glad when I saw the result really
inspirational meeting with jody williams
who has won the nobel peace prize for
her work on land mine campaigns if you
watching sister and transparent which I
I never say anything sacred and say
whatever the hell I wanted people don't
idea that stuff don't come listen to me
right but always transparent always
follow through with what i said i was
going to do and even if they didn't like
me any the opposition the military be
respectively because they knew that I
was a no person of my word Anton embel
we talked about global health research
and just how little data there is but
also how much little is known about the
real health impacts of FGM and lastly a
couple of media interviews
CNN Associated Press TV I spoke with the
BBC with the Sunday Times so a lot of
coverage going on hopefully just getting
the word out and spread in a wide